it is possible to really like what you
do and really like your job but also
know that maybe you work a bit too much
and maybe it's time to think about
letting go of this obsession with work
or productivity or whatever
anna codriorado welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me
you were just telling me that you have
de-optimized your week the
anti-productivity week
yeah i have uh so
normally
i'm all for any productivity hack um
i'm signed up to pomodoro techniqueing
bullet journaling calendar blocking
making sure i've got a really solid
morning routine um but i thought as an
experiment i would see what would happen
if i threw all of that out
and basically did the opposite of what i
would normally do and actively try to
de-optimize my week
has been super interesting because it's
really shown to me the stuff that does
really work and also the stuff that is
kind of a waste of time um
and the biggest takeaway for me or the
biggest surprise the biggest thing i was
not expecting to happen is
i had so much more spontaneity in my
week and so many things happened that i
don't think would have happened would
have otherwise happened had i been just
bumbling about doing my normal very
rigid stuff
so for example on wednesday morning
i
woke up and in the absence of normally
going about my kind of set list of
things i do in the morning
i was like
what should i do
and i thought you know what i've been
really wanting to go to the there's a
new leisure center that's open to where
i live and they do yoga classes and i
was like you know what i'm just i'm
gonna go and try one and there's a
library right next door so i'm going to
work from the library which is something
that i never do i just i'm always in my
home office um so i went went to the old
class
okay the year glass itself not that
great but still
you know it's good to move your body
first thing in the morning um but then
in the library i found a copy of my own
book
which i was just really not expecting
because i live in a small town um the
library's really tiny and they're it's
mainly kind of just kids books but they
had a really small section on jobs and i
think it's called jobs and business and
there i found my book on the shelf which
was just so joyful and something that
just gave me this kind of
boost that i didn't even know that i
needed and it's it's honestly something
i just i wouldn't i wouldn't have had
that
it's you know one of those sort of small
moments of
enjoyment in my week that i just
otherwise wouldn't have had because i
normally am so rigid and so kind of must
be focused on getting as much out of my
day as possible um
so yeah it's been great it's been really
really interesting
there's a tension between
serendipity
and productivity right the the fact that
we try and control our days we try and
make them predictable we try and find
out okay what works but this is the
essence of productivity i'm going to do
a bunch of different things to try and
get something out of my day and over
time the things that seem to help me get
more out of my day are things i'm going
to repeat to do but as you said you know
if you're time blocking the the
opportunity for you to go to the new
library you go i haven't been to a
library and worked effectively before
why am i going to go and try and do that
now and the same thing happens i'm out
here in new york so my
entire schedule is upside down so for me
everything that i do is brand new and
there's so many more opportunities for
serendipity i went to a sports bar last
night to watch some basketball game and
this rapper that was sat next didn't
know his rapper this dude from barcelona
sat next to me that's a rapper starts
telling me about his tour that's a cool
story that i've got so there is this
tension oddly between sort of living
life
and having
variable high intensity enjoyable
serendipitous moments and drilling
productivity and continuing to iterate
on the stuff that you know works
100 um i was thinking about that just
today and it's interesting you're
describing it as serendipity and
productivity and i think that's totally
true but i think for me what i've
realized is somewhere along the line i
confused productivity with creativity
and
they are
they're not the same thing and similarly
productivity is a thing that you can
measure it's quantifiable it's about as
you say
being the most doing doing something in
the most efficient or the the quickest
way possible whereas more often than not
with creativity you don't know how long
something is going to take you don't
there is no
clear end destination
um the way i've kind of been thinking
about it is
it's the difference between when you
you you know you you take a walk it's
kind of how you you can take a walk in
different ways so you can
walk to
the local post office in order to get
your steps in for that day and then also
run that errand and take that off your
list or
you can just take a walk for no reason
and just walk aimlessly around either a
new area you know maybe you're visiting
new york or wherever it might be or just
your own area and your own neighborhood
and just take a walk for no reason and
then come across some amazing discovery
or kind of just and just have that
enjoyment just have that
experience of exploration um that's kind
of how i've been thinking about the two
and it is a tension because
at least for me i am someone who i
actually like order and i like planning
and scheduling it i enjoy putting things
on my calendar
um
but too much of it as i have realized
through this experiment does really
hinder my creativity um and equally i
don't think i could you know i think i'm
i'm a freelancer so in theory i could be
a digital nomad and travel the world and
you know have certain serendipitous
moments every day but i know myself and
i know that i would feel very
overwhelmed by that um and actually i
used to live in new york and i it was it
was a very overwhelming city for me to
be in um that kind of constant not
knowing of how long am i going to be
here for or what's you know what chaos
is this next day going to bring it's too
much so there is something about there
is a kind of goldilocks element to both
productivity and creativity of
you don't you know
we're not robots we can't
there is a limit to how much we can
optimize ourselves and then for me at
least
my goal with productivity is it is to
enable my creativity and so i think
that's for me where this tension
really plays up and where it comes in
and just making sure or at least what
i've become really aware of at the
moment is
finding that balance where i'm getting
the most out of those of the hacks that
do work
but not
kind of co-opting my ability to actually
be creative
what were the hacks that your
unproductive week told you were the most
effective ones
so anything where i'm making a decision
batch batching my decision making i
think
works for me or also kind of just batch
tasking and so what i did is
i i kind of applied this i de-optimized
everything so including the stuff
outside of work so not just the things i
actually did in my working hours but
also outside okay here so this is a this
is kind of a dumb example but one that
for me really kind of
came up
um i started putting
courgettes or as americans call them
zucchinis in my porridge in the morning
and why uh
because it i wanted to get more greens
into my diet i actually
yeah so you honestly you can't taste it
i actually like courgette so i'm fine
with it but honestly
yeah
i am and it is it's a great way to get
more vitamins and honestly you can't
taste it
um
uh but anyway so and like i said i
actually like the taste of crochet so
it's fine but you cannot taste it anyway
so you've got to grate that in like i'm
not chopping you have to like grate it
so at some point i realized what is a
lot more efficient is if at the
beginning of the week i just stick my
courgette in the blender and like zap it
up put it in a tupperware and then just
put a couple of spoonfuls in every
morning this week i was grating the
stupid crochet every single morning what
happened
by the end of the week there's no
there's a half-used courgette in the
fridge that is i'm i was i couldn't this
morning i looked and i was like yeah you
know what i'm not putting the courgette
into the stupid porridge um forget it
and it's also frustrating me a waste of
courgette because now that's going in
the bin anyway um
but i think also the decision the
decisions as well so stuff like
normally i would sit down at the
beginning of the week and work out a
meal plan for the rest of the week so
that it doesn't come to the end of the
day and then my partner and i have that
very frustrating conversation of what's
for dinner tonight i don't know i need
to think about it um all of that is how
all of that is done in one go um so
those were things that really kind of
stood out for me
um as things that actually do help
um
and it's interesting because
calendar blocking is something that i
thought used to really work for me
but what i've come to realize is that
it's just about having a
a very vague plan of action so on the
days where i was kind of just going from
project to project and not not without
any direction i found that quite
stressful and quite overwhelming um and
i really did miss having just a skeleton
list of things that you know in the
morning i'm going to focus on this in
the afternoon i'm going to focus on that
but what i didn't miss is having between
11 and 130 i'm going to
work on this very specific task
um so yeah that was that was really
interesting for me but yeah like i said
it was the um i do think that decision
fatigue at least for me is very real and
if you can front load those decisions
and just kind of deal with them in a
batch
or like or anything put the sort the
course out cause you out in one go
anything that you can do in one go
that for me does really work yeah but
that that's been one of the biggest
things that i've been able to stick to
my
my ability to i swim in these circles
i'm friends with ali abdal and we talk
about the fact that i'm ridiculously
inefficient even though i know what i
should be doing but the things that i
have managed to stick to that have
stayed with me is batching so uh every
day on a wednesday is all of the
podcasts need to be done planning for
the advertisers blah blah blah um once a
week i do my emails once a week things
that will take sub 30 seconds will just
get an email response immediately as and
when they come through all of the long
things scheduling in guests dealing with
whatever it is for work stuff like that
i just do that on usually a friday
thursday or friday also doing emails on
a friday is good because it means that
you don't get a response until the
monday so you don't end up having this
constant back and forth a lot of people
say oh well if you just schedule the
email until when you've finished your
emails then your replies will have come
through after you've finished inbox zero
go yeah but just do it at a time when no
one else is working and it's absolutely
sweet so um yeah batching batching is a
a big one
going back to the creativity
conversation do you think then that
creativity can be hacked at all
absolutely not
um
i
i actually wrote about this a couple of
years ago and the title is creativity
can't be hacked
um because you
you need
you need that
those messy and uncomfortable parts
they have to exist i mean again i
suppose kind of to take this back a step
um
what do we mean when we say can
creativity be hacked like are we talking
about can we find a shortcut to do
creativity faster
can we
avoid the discomfort that comes with
creativity can we generate ideas
you know exponentially can we make more
ideas in a shorter amount of time if
that's what we mean by hacking
creativity i think no because i think
that discomfort is a critical part
of the creative process
um
because
i just think that's
that's kind of how how it just works i
sort of
when i'm writing so my you know my
creativity is mainly around writing and
the way i think about it is
i'm writing something and then i
inevitably get to this point in the
process where
i've lost in all faith in the essay or
the article or the book or whatever it
might be and just think that's it this
thing is
uh i'm screwed like there's this is all
falling apart there's no way forward
and then somehow and i don't even
actually really know how
i move something around
i step back from it
stuff happens that i can't explain and
suddenly it works
and the thing has somehow magically come
together and the only way i what i liken
it to is moving house so whenever you
move house there will always come a
point where you are sat on the floor
either in tears or very nearly
crying looking at all of your stuff
and all of your boxes and thinking there
is no way that that stuff is going to
fit in those boxes
also in time for the movers to come
um
and then
somehow you've turned around you put a
few things somewhere
and done that tetris with um the packing
and it's all packed and it's done
and that always happens and you you
there's no way i've never had a moving
experience in the same way that i've
never had a proper creative experience
where that discomfort hasn't existed is
just kind of a fact fact of it um i do
think there are things you can do
to
give yourself a better chance
and um
improve your experience or increase the
likelihood of creativity being able to
happen sort of engender a creative
atmosphere
exactly but i don't think you can
shortcut your way out of
the uncomfortable and messy parts of
creativity do you think that i would
definitely say that this is the case
that when i try to
hack my way through creativity that it
actually works adversarially to the
creative process as well i'm trying to
come up with something so if i try and
uh binaural beats and right well i'm
gonna list
youtube um and episode titles is a good
example of this i need to come up with a
compelling title that's going to tell
people what this episode's about and
it's also going to have to be
eye-catching but it can't be too
click-baity but it can't be whatever
whatever right so there's all these
parameters running around
and if i was to say right okay so i'm
going to write the first thing that
comes to mind and i'm going to iterate
on that 10 times i'm going to do
whatever whatever
no just go for a walk and think about it
and listen to some music or something
and you'll come back and you end up
having it so in a weird way
creativity gets hacked with anti it can
be hacked but it's the hacks that we
think of as hacks usually are the
opposite of the things that we do to get
creativity you know just leave listen to
some music go to the gym and think about
whatever it is that you're doing
and also what i would add to that is
it's never the same thing so
maybe you're trying to figure out the
headline for your episode or whatever
you might be doing and you went off and
had a shower and it came to you in the
shower that doesn't mean that next time
you're trying to come up with the
episode title if you take a shower the
answer is going to come to you in the
shower you might need to do something
else and sometimes you might have to do
20 things until you finally work it out
and sometimes it you know that's the
other part of it that hack kind of
implies that there is this blueprint and
that if someone if i'd either if i did
it before or if this thing worked for
someone else then it's going to work for
me um this piece that i wrote about it
this piece uh where i kind of explored
this in which i wrote about how i don't
think it can be hacked i um i spoke to a
bunch of people for it and i heard from
this one guy who was like yeah i read
somewhere probably on reddit that um
if if you have more blood to your head
you're more creative so he hung he hung
off the side of his sofa so that he the
blood would rush to his head and all
that happened is that he is that he got
a headache you know there was kind of
because it you know maybe someone lay
down once with their head upside down
and had the idea for
the next greatest book
that doesn't mean it's gonna necessarily
work for you and i do think that we do
have this um
urge to
if someone else has done this
particularly someone quote successful
has done something that if we too could
just replicate what they did then
we'll be golden too
that's what everyone's trying to do
right that's why that's why ali abdel's
got two and a half million youtube subs
you know people look at his content and
they go wow
if i watched his video about typing at
240 words per minute i can type it maybe
i will get closer towards doing that or
the pomodoro technique or atomic habits
or whatever it might be right this is
what people are doing they're trying to
model
off of other successful people who have
managed to get the outcomes they want
from a process which they've explained
which this person is now going to begin
to try and do but
with creativity
it is so
infuriatingly pedestrian encounter and
kind of its own animal and yet the
harder that you push that being said
i'm pretty creative if i have a bad
meditation session it's almost always
because i've had a good creative session
when i should have been thinking about
my breath and
one of my friends johnny
very frequently has a notepad and pen
next to where he meditates because
that's how many ideas he has when he's
meditating which obviously isn't the
purpose of the meditation but um
sort of when it comes it comes i suppose
he also has and this was a life hack
that we featured a little while ago um
have you seen
waterproof paper and pencils i've heard
about them i'm pretty sure i heard about
them from ali
yeah they're love notes they're called
or you can get them on amazon and
they're meant for
i think they're meant for leaving
cute messages to your other half
in the shower and it's like a little
notepad and you can tear them off and
throw it away and the pencils were and
it is pretty spectacular this paper and
this pencil writes and then it gets wet
and nothing happens uh but johnny uses
that because he he says that he has at
least 50 of his ideas while he's
showering um so he's just got got that
done so okay so if you can't hack
creativity what are the things let's say
that you've got a day where you need to
be as creative as possible what are the
sort of things that you're going to try
and do to engender that environment
i think again it really varies it kind
of varies on
the
how critical
that creative
than that need to be creative is so as
someone who
whose job relies on ideas and being
creative
something that i try to separate out are
the
pro the creative projects that i'm doing
for money
and the ones that pay my bills and then
the ones that i keep back and do for
myself
um
and i think one of the things i do is
just trying to find a bit of balance to
have space to do both of those things um
i mean i do sometimes i will sometimes
sit and try to come up with ideas but
what i what i tend to do is i also have
a place just on my phone in in the um
notes app
um
where i'm constantly writing down
kernels of ideas
and then i do sometimes do just
development
like i'll
carve out a couple of hours and i'll go
through this list a lot of it is garbage
um and just take those ideas and
actually try to develop them and i'll
kind of i'll start by
um
googling the idea has anyone else
written anything about this maybe poll
people on twitter see if they've got
anything interesting to say
um
i do a lot of reading so as a writer for
me a big the other half of the writing
process is reading i would just go down
so many rabbit holes and just read stuff
um sometimes also do that on youtube as
well and just watch watch a bunch of
youtube videos
um
i i do find for me
it is kind of
if i'm actively trying to be creative it
is quite a doing process um
i will also just sit and this actually
just happens a lot more infrequently
than it should but i will just sit and
try to write something
basically i think what's really
interesting is that sometimes something
will have will have worked and we'll
just try to keep replicating it and it
just it doesn't
um
like we can't get there again
um
but yeah i don't know it's um
it's so hard to pinpoint exactly
what i'm doing because i only realize
something has worked
after it has after i've actually had the
idea or after i've actually done
something that has been
has actually kind of made has had a
creative output if that makes sense
definitely having a list each week is a
really cool idea so the newsletter that
i write each week i need to come up with
three things that i've learned i learned
tons of things but if i didn't ever look
for them if i wasn't ever writing them
down then it would be really difficult
and then it means that when it comes to
writing the newsletter at the end of the
week i've got 10 things to choose from
that i could have as the body of it
there's this tweet and this article and
this conversation i had with a friend
and this story from whatever might have
happened
so yeah i think purposefully looking for
um
little inspirations of creativity
because that's kind of how creativity is
right
creativity isn't a big process it's the
genesis of the process the process is
the work that you do after the
creativity you know tons of books almost
all of the sort of popular science
pop psych stuff is a core concept
fleshed out into 80 000 words so
finding
finding those
little bits of inspiration that's
exactly what you're looking for and i
think spreading that across the week
just kind of grazing on
little
tidbits of creativity that seems to that
definitely makes it easier for me it
also means that your research period is
going to be much more simple because
it's okay i'm looking at this as opposed
to looking for something and then
looking at whatever it is so i think
that's good um the the article that got
me onto your work which i absolutely
love and i wrote a newsletter about was
productivity dysmorphia
so can you take me through that
yeah um
so this is a term i
made up
to
refer to
when you can't see
your own
success
where
there is a disconnect between
feeling success
well between being successful and
feeling successful
so
i
have kind of felt this for quite a long
time
and
it
really manifested most recently which is
what finally spurred me to write this
article
when my first book came out so my book
came out i
became a published author
and yet i
really struggled to
identify as an author and also to accept
that my book was
real i mean obviously i know it's real
but to accept that it was a real
achievement so people would say how
proud i must be of myself
and i was
but i couldn't i was not feeling as
enthusiastic and as proud as these
people were kind of projecting onto me
and what all that was going on in my
head was
yeah but the book came out on lockdown
so i didn't get a proper book launch and
it's not um
you know it wasn't at the time it wasn't
in a book shop because well because
literally
books were not being stocked in any
bookshop um
and also it's non-fiction it's not a
novel so
that doesn't count
as i say these things i realize how
ridiculous it is but these were the
things that were going on in my head
just all of these things i was telling
myself to diminish the achievement and
um it's not the first time it's happened
it's happened before the other time the
other big time i remember happening was
um
i
had a um
i wrote a story for the new york times
and it made it onto its front page
um
and
and kind of as far as journalists go
getting a front page on byline on the in
the new york times is kind of
like it's really up there it's that was
always that that kind of achievement was
something i didn't even ever
think would be possible i didn't even
have it on the list like book has always
been on the list but that sort of thing
wasn't even on the list because i just
didn't think it was going to happen
and
same thing
oh it doesn't count because it was a
co-by-line there was another reporter's
name on it and it wasn't supposed to be
on the front page but some other you
know all of this stuff that i kind of
just told myself to just diminish the
achievement um and i um
again do what i do
as a journalist i ask other people if
they've experienced this and then take
it to academics and experts to see their
take on it
when i tweeted out asking people
if they've also have this disconnect of
um not being able to see their own
achievements i was absolutely inundated
with replies and really interestingly
from such a wide range of people
um i've heard you know i heard from
women from men from other authors but
also from sex workers from people in all
fields in so many kind of across all
industries okay fine fair enough of
course it's twitter so it's still
you know take that um with a grain of
salt but was overwhelmed by how many
people related to this
um
and then yeah so then i went off and
spoke to a bunch of experts and the way
i the way i sort of think about
productivity dysmorphia is
that
productivity is the thing that spurs us
to try and achieve something but
productivity dysmorphia
robs us from our ability to savor the
fruit of that achievement
um
and
i kind of found that it
it sits somewhere between anxiety
burnout and imposter syndrome um
it's not it's a bit of all of them but
not quite fully one of them uh the the
big the thing that people kind of came
back and said
first and foremost was but this is just
straight-up imposter syndrome and for me
the difference is why i don't think it's
imposter syndrome
is that
whilst i really relate to imposter
syndrome and have it in some aspects of
my life at least as far as work is
concerned i don't have this fear of
getting found out i'm actually quite
confident in my
my work abilities um i know that i'm
good at my job and know that i'm a good
reporter i know that i'm a good writer i
don't have this
the kind of hallmark of imposter
syndrome is getting found out to be
fraudulent um and i
i don't have that at least not in a work
context have it in other areas of my
life but not in a work context um
so that for me is why imposter syndrome
never quite fully
it just didn't quite ring true for me
um
and
kind of same with burnout because yes
i've experienced burnout but i've also
had this thing happen to me when i've
not been burned out so um that's kind of
where i landed and it's been really
interesting it's been um loads of people
seem to have taken interest in this term
um it's kind of taken on a life of its
own
um
but it's been really it's been great to
sort of start having all these
conversations and kind of connect with
people and find out that
they also experience this the way that i
see it imposter syndrome is
forward-looking
productivity dysmorphia is
backward-looking so imposter syndrome
for the most part
it is the persistent lack of belief in
your ability to get the work done
despite the fact that you have continued
to get the work done and all of your
that's the retrospective productivity
dysmorphia is
in it by its very nature i have done
some work but i i could have would have
should have done more higher this is you
you tarnish it and and and sort of
downgrade any of the achievements
there's two elements to it that i think
i can't remember whether you went into
this in the in the article
what you've used as examples are large
projects which you have got to and then
something's happened which has been
great uh and you've downplayed the
how much that should be celebrated or
how much that resonates with you and how
sort of virtuous you feel you're like
the line between your efforts and the
outcomes that you've got
i also think that there's another
element of this which is on a smaller
scale and on a daily basis which is
simply i did a lot of work today but i
should have done more that's another
element of it which isn't quite the same
i don't think it's not necessarily about
tarnishing the
um grandeur of the outcome this one is
more to do with lack of volume or
feelings of
inefficiency so for instance
i haven't been in an office for
a very long time
and i
work from home or sometimes i go out and
work in coffee shops quite rarely and um
you see your own inefficiencies from a
front row seat you see every time that
cold turkey pops up and blocks you from
accessing that website that you said
that you weren't going to use or the
youtube rabbit hole that you go down
that you promised yourself that you
wouldn't have done or the lunch that you
said was going to take 20 minutes and
took 40 or you see all of these things
right and i you think oh god you know i
should be doing more ali abdul will be
doing more and then i went into an
office to go and record a podcast
a year ago something like that
and there were all of these people
[ __ ] sat around doing nothing i'm
like
oh
[ __ ] i forgot just how inefficient
people in an office actually are
and that really was
it reminded me look you you probably are
still wildly inefficient and you
probably do need to spend less time on
youtube however
it's the work that you've done to get
yourself to this stage is really really
good um so yeah did you look at or do
you see this sort of bifurcation that
i'm talking about here one being
tarnishing large achievements the other
being
an inability to accept that you have
done work today congratulations ana pat
yourself on the back
a hundred percent i mean part of what
we're talking about here and this is why
i
did mention that i do think anxiety
plays a role in this is
because what we're talking about here is
a feeling of not being good enough um
that you know i've not done enough this
achievement isn't big enough or even if
it is i'm still going to diminish it
that's that's a feel that is
that that's about these feelings of
inadequacy basically and they can happen
on small and large scales um
as to the point about
um
people who work in offices um versus
self-employed people
that ring is really really true for me
because honestly my whole
productivity journey or this whole
interest in productivity culture only
came about after i started working for
myself and it came about because i
realized how
actually there were so many things i was
doing when i worked in an office that
just were not working uh that were just
really inefficient or i mean i knew this
at the time i always used to i i would
stand on the subway platform in new york
and i would think to myself how dumb it
is that we have evolved so far and yet
we have concluded that the best thing to
do is for all of us
to get up
and go in the same direction every day
with everyone else
and then come back at the same time
going in the opposite direction with
everyone else
why can't we stagger
you know the time that we need to be in
the office
and i would mention this to people and
they would say well that's just the way
it is and like you know what would be
the alternative and
we had a pandemic and we saw what the
alternative could be but anyway um
this whole journey really was very much
triggered by me starting to work for
myself and i do think
on a really basic level it starts from
the fact that
i am now fundamentally paid for my
output rather than my input so
when you work in an office of course of
course you have to actually do your job
and if you don't eventually you will get
fired but there is a lot that you can
get away with because you are being paid
to have your bum on the seat
whereas
i am being paid to deliver something
my editors really don't care
how and when
five minutes or five hours
yeah they don't care how long it takes
they don't care where i am they don't
care how i do it they just want the
article
when i worked
in-house when i had
a full-time job although i do hate that
term because i do have a full-time job
now but when i had an office job when i
was employed for an employer
my mom had to be on the seat
and the first time i ever got in serious
trouble at work was because
i basically left work a few hours early
on a friday afternoon when there was
because there was no work to be done
because the
company was going through a um a
restructure and there was literally no
work to be done and i got in so much
trouble and i remember saying but there
was
nothing to be like there was you know
nothing for me to do
and i was told but you are paid to be
here between the hours of whatever nine
and six
um
and
things probably have evolved since then
this was
i'm not convinced that they will have
evolved i don't i think that a big part
of
the way that office work works
is that
it's a signal to the rest of the crew
that if you're suffering i'm here
suffering with you as well so i've been
a club promoter for a long time and a
big part of our job
i don't need to be on the front door of
a nightclub the boys that i have that
work for me the managers they understand
inside out how to run that front door
they understand how to run the front
door not as well as me
but would that be difficult but they
understand how to run it nearly as well
as i do so
i don't need to be there why am i there
i'm there as a signal to the guy that
manages the nightclub to say me
[ __ ] promoter guy i am here freezing
my tits off on the front door of this
nightclub at
1am
in the middle of newcastle's winter with
you as well because you're here
big chunk of it is just signaling and
the same thing goes for the people that
are in the office well maybe you
finished your work early because you
were more efficient or something like
that
but
we're a team here there's some sort of
tribal mentality and if such and such is
lagging and still has graft to do friday
at 3 p.m anna you still need to be in
the office despite the fact that you've
completed yours because we're a unit
yeah and
it sucks for that person who is just
more efficient um
and you're actually
you're genuinely disincentivized from
being efficient yeah if doing if doing
more work more intensely and more
efficiently results in you just being
given more work or having big lulls of
time where you don't do work because
those are the only two things that are
going to happen you either sit about and
do nothing after you've finished your
work or you are given more work to do
and if you're not remunerated for that
with either free time or more money
you're actively disincentivized from
being productive 100
i mean it just makes me think of that
episode of friends when ross is
unemployed because he screamed at his
boss and
joey's teaching him how to be better at
being unemployed and make stretching out
a task
stretching out the tasks of the week
over of the day over the week so he had
only five things to do and he's like
that you do that over the course of the
week you don't do that all of that on a
monday morning um it was funny because
that's how people that's how the office
works
uh but yeah that has always been my
experience you know i remember asking
also to work from home one day a week to
write because funnily enough it's a lot
easier to write
in quiet
and was told no you can't because there
are other members of the team who can't
be trusted to work from home so
rather than sort that problem out it's
easier to punish the person who we know
is a good worker and we'll just
figure out a way to do it you know
they're optimizing for the worst common
denominator for the least effective
yeah i mean you know the remote work
revolution was way way way overdue i
think and you know a lot of bad things
came out of the pandemic but that's one
of the
definite advantages talking about the
problems of work you did a big deep dive
into the anti-work subreddit didn't you
what's what is that for the people that
aren't familiar with it
so
um
the anti-work subreddit is a
it was the largest the fastest growing
reddit from last year
and um
it's been around for a really long time
but really blew up during the pandemic
and it's basically a forum for people to
talk about these pretty radical ideas of
completely abolishing work
um
and it really blew up because um
particularly in america there were there
was kind of wave of people who were
super frustrated with their working
conditions particularly in the service
sectors
and they texted their bosses to say that
they quit so they quit over text and
then they took screenshots of these
texts and they put it on the anti-work
uh subreddit and those went viral and
the whole thing um
the whole thing blew up and now it's got
i think it's pushing at two million
subscribers
um what was really fascinating so i
spent a couple of months reporting on
this what was really fascinating is
this idea of anti-work out as in
anti-work
as a kind of political or or sort of
political philosophy i suppose
um
is it it's not it kind of
it's not new but it's not vowed but it's
not new either
um and it has its roots in quite far
left
ideologies so marxism
anarchism and even kind of you could
really get in the weeds of it kind of
like post anarchism and all of this kind
of stuff
um
it's quite heavily tied to the idea of
um there being no state
so
to kind of take this back a step when we
say like abolish work we think well how
no that's good how's that going to work
if we don't work how are we going to
make money the point is to think about
what would a society that is not
centered around money and not centered
around us having to quote unquote earn a
living and exchange our labor
for money what would that look like so
it's not about
ending work within the current system
that we know it but it's kind of i mean
really this is about dismantling the
whole system of capitalism
um
everything that's everything everything
any social movement
sneaks marxism or communism in through
the back door there's these people that
thought that they were just leaving a
job they just thought they were leaving
the job and texting their boss and
telling him that they weren't going to
come into work later on and then three
months later
marxism
yeah and what's been really interesting
is that there has been so when i was
reporting on the story and this has kind
of got i think it's got worse um in the
group since and there's been actually
been quite a lot of drama since i wrote
the piece um that i'm not actually fully
up to date on but um so it's
like any big movement particularly one
that starts online and starts to starts
to kind of move and spill into the real
world there's a lot of teething problems
because it's really easy to say behind a
computer screen you know let's dismantle
capitalism and let's do this and do that
it's a lot harder to actually then turn
that into actual action um but so to
your point
there was quite a split in the group so
there were the people the kind of let's
call them sort of the
um the og anti-work kind of the um long
time members
who
they're all about these kind of quite
extreme lefty views
um
and then there are the people who've
moved in since the pandemic who
basically realized yeah work sucks and i
hate it um and i need a place to vent
about it but fundamentally i
i want to improve work and i want to
exist within the system but i just want
it to be better
um and and to me that was what the
really interesting tension is because
when you when you when you realize the
system
is broken or isn't working what do you
do
do you find a way to exist within it
or do you try
to overturn it and change it and i think
that's something that
um
so many of us kind of do feel that
tension because um
it's really interesting you know uh
i've seen a lot of critique in general
there's kind of this trend in internet
writing at the moment
of pointing out that there are people
who have pointed to the failures of
capitalism but they themselves aren't
doing enough to
tear down the system
i don't it's not possible for any one
individual to tear down the system i
mean what does that even actually look
like in practice um
and
i think so many of us are just thinking
about well you know what
there are so many things that i don't
like about this but also
i'm not sure that i see what the
alternative would look like i'm not sure
that you know i'm not a marxist i'm not
a captain i'm not a anarchist i'm not a
whatever i'm you know none of these
labels quite seem to fit quite right and
none of the kind of ideology or theory
seemed to look quite right either
um and so really i mean the actual heart
of the original point of the forum was
just to debate and talk
and then then there became this pressure
of now there are so many people and
there's so much media interest and
suddenly it became this pressure of this
this group somehow which is just a bunch
of regular people talking on the
internet is somehow now supposed to come
up with all of the answers
for everything that's wrong with our
society um so it's been really really
interesting and really really kind of
fascinating to watch unfold um
and i've had some really
great conversations with so many of the
people who are members
um and then also kind of um
lots of academics as well because there
is sort of there's a dotted line to
another movement which is called
post-work which is very much more
in the academic space
and that is also deals in this idea of
critiquing work as we know it
and um thinking about what what some
alternatives might look like
and to my mind i just think you know
what even if it's something like
even if it's like you know what some of
these ideas are a bit too radical for me
or a bit too lefty or whatever it might
be
there's still so much in there that is
actually really um really worth engaging
with and to a large extent this idea of
work and how it doesn't work is actually
something that cuts right across the
political spectrum because actually
there are people who
they they you know might be on the
complete opposite side of um
uh yeah of the political scale
who still also are sat in offices and
really hating their jobs lots of people
are disgruntled with their work it's not
just a phenomenon from people on the
left was was getting exposed to this one
of the reasons that you've
decided to try and do less work this
year
it definitely
was uh one of the contributing factors
um although i'm not i'm also uh so i i
wrote i wrote a piece recently about how
my goal for this year is to is to do
less and um
i think there's also i'm not the first
person who's kind of come up with that
idea either sort of since i've seen that
piece i've seen lots of other people
also kind of express similar similar
feelings
and um
a lot of people have kind of
misunderstood what anti-work is about
and people kind of think that it is more
about just being fed up with work and
they're sort of they're not aware of
these really radical roots
but doing all of that work and kind of
thinking about it and particularly
reading some of the more um
the more measured texts and speaking to
some of the kind of really well
researched academics
and realizing actually how deep this
problem of work goes that definitely was
a contributing factor but
i mean there's obviously no way for me
to av tests this but i think i probably
would have landed there on my own
anyway because
you know
i really believe that
writers
they write what they need to read
it's kind of how you teach what you need
to learn
and there is a reason why i was
attracted to that anti-work story and so
whether or not i would have written it
um i think i probably would have still
landed in this place of just
re-evaluating my own relationship with
my work my productivity and my ambition
and all of these things um
but it definitely i guess it kind of
gave me the permission to do it sort of
knowing that there are these sort of
there's this sprawling online community
of people who are taking this even more
seriously than i am um
that i think helped there's a quote from
one of your articles where you said i've
managed to unearth a series of
contradictions in myself chief among
them is that i'd very much like to work
less than i currently do and indeed it's
within my power to do so but i still
don't
and that tension again
between the fact that
i actually something else here
i think that there's broadly two types
of people that are really really focused
on productivity
one of them
are the camp that i think both me and
you fall into which is we take pleasure
from doing things well doing things
productively doing things efficiently
getting work done um we genuinely do
however we also see that there's another
element of life that we're probably
missing out on that we know that life
would be better and that we are built
for spending more time in nature for
spending more time away from our screens
for spending less time being worried
about the next achievement whatever it
might be the other side uh
i would put ali into this camp i have a
bunch of other buddies as well who don't
who don't really seem douglas murray is
a good example of this as a writer um
he simply won't stop and he simply has
no desire to stop either the idea of a
balanced life to him
it doesn't it's not something that
factors into his life he sees his life
as a balanced life working all the time
and then picking up his his um
free
elements his spare time wherever he can
and i think that there's broadly two of
those and i think that the tension as
well with what you're talking about here
only really applies to
those of us that have a bit of a desire
for something else outside of it because
if all that you want to do is send it
every single day sat in front of your
desk then crack on um
i've managed to unearth a series of
contradictions chief among them is that
i'd like to do less work than i
currently do and indeed it's within my
power but i still don't why do you think
that contradiction's there
if i think i think if i knew why it was
there
i would be able to uh solve this problem
and kind of be at peace with it can i
can i give you a potential reason why i
think it might be there please do yes i
think that i think that you and you
obviously derive satisfaction from doing
your work
and that you know
the grind and iterating on the things
that you do are going to continue to get
you success
changing that is a bad idea because you
have found a successful solution
letting go of that i think is just
primarily the problem i think that the
difficulty comes from
[Music]
not doing something which you know
brings you success and i think it's
the urgent will always get in the way of
the important
in the same way as the
um how would you say the dopamine system
will always overtake the serotonin
system you're always going to chase a
goal ahead from finding peace and
pleasure because you know that the goal
is
it's it feels more urgent it feels more
immediate or at least that's my
explanation for why i feel that way
yeah i think
that does make sense to me i think
that's definitely
if not all of it a really big part of it
because that's the thing is that as you
said like i am someone who likes work i
like what i do
um
you know i
i feel so blessed that i get to do stuff
like this and call it my job
um and that
for the large part i don't really have
to answer to anyone of course you know
i've like you know i still have to be
polite and i've got clients and i've got
deadlines and i've got stuff but i
really am the kind of like master of my
own destiny and and i really do think
i've got the greatest job in the world
um
but then also i do know there is so much
more to life than work
um
and also there's this weird thing at the
moment where it's suddenly really
unfashionable to be you know hustling is
not is that it's not fashionable at
least not in the sort of circles i'm
swimming in
um
you know the girl boss is dead um
and all of this kind of stuff so there's
that going on but then there's also you
know
this has really been amplified at least
for me with the pandemic because during
the pandemic there was nothing else to
do i was not baking banana bread i was
working on my book i was working because
that is was
something i enjoyed doing
and pretty much the only thing i could
do all competition for working had been
removed yeah
exactly um
so it is
it is a it's a it's a really tough one
it's kind of almost it's almost like i
sometimes have these conversations where
i kind of
i do think there are people who just
view jobs as jobs just as paychecks um
and they're not necessarily interested
in careers they're just interested in
exchanging their labor for money
basically so they can do stuff outside
of work um
i'm i'm just not one of those people and
sometimes i do have days where i wish i
was where i could take my worse like
work less seriously where i could get
where i could teach myself to care less
about my work but i just can't
um
so yeah there's all of that kind of
swelling around um i think it also for
me what
moving i
so i've i've always been a journalist my
whole career and i've written about lots
of different things over the course of
my career um and i'm in this space at
the moment where i'm writing and
thinking a lot about productivity and
work and careers and stuff like that
and it does sometimes this kind of meta
element of my job i think also can makes
this maybe sometimes a bit worse seeps
into everything that you do you know if
you're chilling out by reading oliver
berkman's four thousand weeks but then
you've also got a podcast with him but
then you were also going to write an
article on it but then would i have read
this book
had i not been well yeah because it's a
pretty good book and then you start to
go hang on have i managed to have i got
like stockholm syndrome to my own job
here
exactly where does the line between what
i do for fun and what i do for work
where does that finish well i get to do
something that i love for for work well
actually how much would i love it if
this wasn't my work
just over and over again
you know what's really interesting as
you say that it makes me think about so
the last the the actual the last time i
had a um
an in-house a staff job
um i was a music journalist
and covering the type of music that at
the time i absolutely loved
um
i still have not recovered from how much
that ruined my enjoyment of music
um
and i don't have that anymore you know
you're to your point because i i read
oliver burtman's book i interviewed him
for my podcast and um
i loved reading his book in my free time
i gifted that book to my dad i've spoken
about that length with my friends
recommend it to people it's a joy for me
to talk about that and it was
had a positive impact on me reading that
book
um i don't know what happened to the
music to the love of music though but
having a job in that space
destroyed that love for me and even now
i don't really
i don't listen to new music anymore um
i'm just i live in i mean i listen to
music i'm not a total freak um but i i
kind of live in this bubble of i just
prefer to listen to stuff i already know
um i have no idea what's going on
in those kind of spaces anymore again
i've said for ages that if there's one
way
to
turn a love into a labor
it's to commercialize it
as soon as you do what you do for fun
for work
the the game has changed and that's a
price that i think far more people need
to pay i i need to realize that they're
going to pay i did this video a while
ago about 10 reasons why you shouldn't
work for yourself and it was all of the
bad things about being self-employed the
fact that you're both the task master
you're the organ grinder and the monkey
you never know when you're done holidays
aren't holidays you don't get sick pay
you can't get a house because you need
three years of sa 302s blah blah blah
all of these things right all of this
stuff that happens that comes through
and you can turn the thing that you
think well i i if i did my passion for
work
then
my job would be the thing that i love
yes it would
but you are also going to turn your
passion into a job
that doesn't mean that your job is going
to be your passion it's the other way
around and
there will be times
inevitably if you want to be good at the
thing that you're going to do you're
going to have to work hard which means
that you're going to have to get your
nose to the grindstone stay up late get
up early
battle through creativity blocks and so
on and so forth
and that removes a lot of the joy that
you find one of the reasons that you
enjoy doing the things that you do is
because they're easy and free and
liberating and they don't feel like they
have the time pressure of whatever job
it is you do at the moment you start to
change that and put the same dynamic
that you're trying to escape over the
thing that you now do to escape
there's only one outcome from that
i
also wonder about
whether you do something whether you
turn that passion into a job and you do
it for someone else or whether you do it
for yourself i totally hear you on the
um
reasons not to be freelance um i've
written a whole book about freelancing
and if there is one piece of advice
it's called you're the business um it's
this one right here this lovely blue one
um and if there's one piece of advice
when people ask me should i go freelance
i say to them are you being pushed into
freelancing are you being pulled towards
it because more often than not people
are being pushed into it because they
don't like their current job situation
in which case don't freelance just
get another job um
all of that being said i do wonder
if
doing your passion but for someone else
also plays a role in it because i was a
music journalist for
working on staff at a
a really intense publication
where there were sort of impossible
parameters
and eventually that publication
got shut down and i got my major
redundant and that's how i ended up
freelancing which was the best thing
that ever happened to my career but
sucked at the time um
and
i think that had a role to play because
it was still
it was still the thing i
loved
but not on my own
terms
and i i think also to be honest i think
probably was relevant that it was a
music industry and i think i saw a side
to it that i was not expecting and was
seeing it up you know seeing how the
sausage is made is kind of
a recipe for going vegetarian um
so that might have been a part of it as
well
um but yeah i think this kind of idea of
find a job you love and you won't work a
day in your life is one of the biggest
lies that uh we have been told um and
this idea of
oh if you can just find your passion um
your job won't be a job it's it's just
[ __ ] there's a quote from tim cook
at an all hands apple meeting that he
did and he takes questions from the uh
staff and someone had asked something to
do with the same thing they say if you
find something that you love you'll
never work a day in your life
tim cook thought about it for a moment
and he said yeah they people do say if
you do what you love you will never work
a day in your life at apple i found that
to not be true at all
said you will work harder at this thing
than you ever had before but the tools
will feel light in your hands
i'm like that's cool
that's a cool way to put it
but you need to know that there's a
price that you pay for this this isn't
going to be your passion anymore this is
going to be a business built around
something that you cared about and you
don't know where that's going to go i
it's an unfortunate red pill to drop on
people but you genuinely don't know if
commercializing your passion is going to
destroy your passion for it and not be a
commercial success that's genuinely a
risk you know um what it's like it's
like you and that girl that you lived
next door to and you went to school with
for ages and ages and you never went she
was in relationships and you were in
relationships and you never went out and
you think right okay if we decide to do
this we sacrifice the potential for our
friendship for a relationship which
isn't guaranteed to succeed that's kind
of how i see it
yeah it's so true so yeah that's exactly
what it's like
um
and
it kind of comes back to what we were
saying at the very beginning that
there's no blue there's no blueprint
you're not gonna know if something's
gonna work until you try it and just
because it worked for someone doesn't
mean that it's gonna work for you just
because there is there's a content
creator out there or youtuber who
whoever or writer who's
turned their
passion
into their career and they've made it
work and they talk about how brilliant
it is that doesn't mean that that's
going to be
the same thing
for you um
and i don't know it's it's tough it's
also i think it comes back to how
at least when i was
going through school and university
we weren't taught about thinking about
careers in terms of how they fit into
our lives we were just taught you must
get a job and the end goal is job which
back then was in an office
um and here is a menu of types of jobs
you can do when you can do these stupid
aptitude tests that always tell you that
you're going to be a teacher
and then they you know their role in the
like the lawyers and the accountants and
all of these people in these
professional fields to show you what the
options are
um but they don't talk about okay if you
want to be
in the creative field this is what your
life might look like or if you're
thinking about living a certain kind of
life
how's your job going to fit into it and
all of these things we just we're not
taught about that even though
we center our whole world our whole
society our whole lives around work
when we're taught about careers we're
not taught about how they fit in
in relation to the rest of our life
um
but i mean
i do feel somewhat optimistic that some
of this stuff is starting to change um
and at least from my experience you know
i'm being asked to come into
universities and um even kind of um
uh like community um centers and stuff
like that to talk to young people about
freelancing and i i never had those
kinds of talks when i was um when i was
those young though that age it was it
was just like these are these rigid
types of jobs that you're going to be
able to do um and i do think that young
people are kind of thinking differently
about this stuff so um
i'm semi-hopeful
one thing to consider i'm aware that i
put a bit of a damp squib on everyone's
dreams of monetizing their passion one
other thing to consider is if you hate
what you're doing at the moment you're
not you're not giving anything up now if
you don't enjoy the relationship you're
in the place that you live the job that
you do
you're literally risking nothing but
what's the worst that happens you get
into another jo you try and make a go of
it and you it
fails and then you go back into a job
that you don't like do you mean like the
one that you have now
at the very least you've closed that
open loop of constantly obsessing over
whether or not that's going to be the
thing and then maybe you find out it was
never the thing in the first place and
you can now think about to start
thinking about what the actual thing is
going to be
um
going back to the
the um
beyond work discussion that's beyond
burger isn't it that's moving past me
anti-work anti-work um going back to
that how do you counteract your
desire to constantly get things done
with productivity given the fact that
you like getting things done you take
value in it but also you have this other
this vision of knowing that not
everything you do should be in the
service of work
how do you know if you're working hard
enough how do you give yourself a break
when you've finished working how do you
counteract this desire to constantly get
stuff done
well so first of all i want to say to
kind of connect these two things that
we've just been talking about is
i think it's really important for people
to be to realize and something that has
been transformative for myself to kind
of grapple with is that it is possible
to to hold two conflicting thoughts in
your head and for both of them to be
true
and that they can exist at the same time
and so for example it is possible to
really like what you do and really like
your job but also know that maybe you
work a bit too much and maybe it's time
to kind of think about letting go of
this obsession with work or productivity
or whatever um i wish i would have come
up with this but unfortunately i can't
take credit for it um there is an essay
in the new york times which someone's
got something the headline is something
something to the effect of you can be
anti-work and have a dream job at the
same time um and i think that's very
true i think you can um be really
critical of the way we work of our um
working environment or even maybe go so
far as the whole system
um but also love your job
because that's kind of that's kind of
how i feel um did you sorry did you hear
there was a story about second wave
feminism uh and the woman separatist
movement in the 70s do you know what
this is
no big group of women decided that the
patriarchy was causing a lot of problems
for them and the solution was to
completely recount men so you had
straight women becoming either
celibate or elected elective lesbians in
a desperate attempt to try and sort of
stick their middle finger up at the
patriarchy and it's kind of what you're
talking about here that the binary
choice that people see with regards to
work is
if i think that there are problems with
the current system of work i therefore
either need to be unemployed or hate my
job
yeah exactly and it's
it's so much more
nuanced than that it's possible
to hold opposing views
and then be true
at the same time and i think that
actually in answer to the actual
question you asked me
that to me is a really key element of
all of this because once you can accept
that and once you can
you know
validate your feelings basically um
things become a lot easier from there
so
if you just remind yourself of those
things then when you do need to take a
break you kind of
you can you can give yourself a break
basically um i mean for me one of the i
mean this is obviously not practical for
everyone to do but for me one of the big
things is that i'm actually moved out
the city so um i
used to live in london and um i moved
out and there's a slower pace of life
around me and slowly slowly that is
filtering
to me as well it's got this kind of
trickle-down effect of when i live
somewhere that's more chilled i become
more chilled um
i kind of also make this say this in a
kind of joking way to people when they
ask me about you know how to get better
at having breaks when you're freelance
um
i tell them to get a dog
because
the dog needs to the dog needs a walk
and the dog is gonna force you to get
out and the dog is going to force you
into nature
and um
just make you have a bit of division
between your working life and your free
life
so it's kind of stuff like that it is
kind of um you know like i said i'm not
saying that the only way to do these
things is to either move to the
countryside or
get a dog but the point is you kind of
have to take some quite intentional and
not necessarily drastic action but
intentional action um if you're serious
about um
about doing these things you actually
have to put the work in it's is i guess
i guess it's kind of
not dissimilar to
uh
this big idea that james clear talks
about which is that um
the the identity the identity
habit if you want to form the habit you
need to film a form and identity around
it so okay i want to be a person who
works less so think to myself at 5 pm
what would a person who worked less do
at this point would they continue to
send emails or do whatever or would they
maybe close their laptop and go for a
walk um it's that kind of thing it's
sort of thinking
like i said it's being intentional about
this stuff um and yeah for me it was
actually taking some quite drastic um
changes and making some quite drastic
changes in my lifestyle
yeah it's a
it's a really interesting tension i
think sort of playing with all of these
different things definitely
getting yourself into the environment
where you are around things that are
happening that you want to do so for
instance i actually
found not the opposite but kind of a
little bit the opposite that the pace of
life in newcastle was too slow for me so
um going to austin where it's super
social there's things happening all the
time there's events on everybody's
training or going shooting or going
south by southwest or
some sort of meditation retreat there's
always things to do so again you know
i'm in a house surrounded by the type of
food that i want to eat i'm in a city
surrounded by the type of activities
that i want to do it's very difficult to
do the sort of thing that you want to do
if there's no one around you doing it so
yeah i think
basically
environment design but just on a an
entire sort of lifestyle scale socially
what are the sort of people that you're
around doing
yeah that's um
[Music]
it'll be interesting it'll be
interesting to see what happens the
progress of remote work
this increasing dissatisfaction with
living for work
um i think
for some people
um the realization that you can get to
your
freedom number whatever you feel like in
terms of your annual income and then
stopping as opposed to being the
boss [ __ ] or the gary v hustle and
grind guy and this is something i i
really need to read a little bit more
about it but it's something i'm really
passionate about saying look
if you have a low level of materialism
if you can be
optimally happy at 100 grand a year
you have a competitive advantage over
people who can't get to that level of
happiness until they hit 10 mil like
that that is genuinely the same as
having a fast metabolism look that
person needs to be on 1800 calories a
day in order to cut you can cut on 2400
calories you can do less work and get
the same outcome that you want but
culture at the moment it's so uncool to
talk about
rest when you're done
you know
rest when you're done or you you don't
need to push yourself beyond where you
need to go i think in the micro that
makes a ton of sense you want to be
competitive you want to get as much out
of yourself as you can but when it comes
to doing things that are in service of
other things like working in service of
money or working in service of freedom
i i don't think that that's true i think
that you get yourself to the stage where
you're comfortable and then you start to
lean further and further and further
into what would i do with my time if i
had as much time as i could and that's
morgan housel's psychology of money says
having wealth is the ability to do what
you want when you want with who you want
for as long as you want and no one can
tell you otherwise
that's it so
yeah i'm hoping his philosophy actually
comes out a little bit more just
san marxism
yeah i mean that's always the sticking
point right is that
um
i mean there's so much to kind of unpack
there it's really interesting so a
couple of things i'll just say quickly
is first of all
um
you know i want to be a person who just
only is intrinsically motivated and i
have my own definition of success
and i want to tune out everything else
but i can't you know i do also
like being able to i don't
i want to be able to go to the party and
say oh you know i do i i do x
and people instantly understand what
that is it's quite tedious and quite
frustrating when you go somewhere and
you're talking to someone and you're
explaining to them they've got this
newsletter
and it's got you know 15 000 subscribers
or whatever
um
and they're just looking at you and that
you know like i'm i i am
i have a i have a membership on my
newsletter a subscription thing like i
actually make money directly through the
newsletter and people are people eyes
are kind of either glazing over or they
just can't compute and they they don't
understand what it is and it's
um i do sometimes have those moments
where i wish i could just say you know
i'm a lawyer or i am a journalist who
has a staff job at the new york times or
whatever um
because actually having those
traditional external markers of success
is just
easier to talk about
um so it would be
i would be lying if i said that i've got
this whole thing licked and that i do my
own thing and i don't care what anyone
thinks and all of that because of course
i do i'm human um
so
there's kind of
that element to it and then
there's another element to it which is
specifically on the money side and as
you say kind of talking about wealth is
that
so many of us
don't know because again it's not
something that was you know financial
literacy and kind of even sort of
financial education
is something that
is just not taught as standard in
schools and even just this kind of
understanding the difference between
wealth and income and that your salary
how much you're paid as a salary isn't
actually
that that's not it's obviously a part of
but it's not the whole indicator of your
wealth and all of these kind of concepts
between the difference between net well
net worth and um income and all of these
things is just stuff that not enough of
us
talk about or know about um and so when
we're thinking of
when we talk about building wealth
there's this kind of like it's it's not
okay to say that that you know i'm out
here trying to build my wealth because
that just it
what people hear is i'm out here just
trying to make as much money as possible
and i just i'm i just want to be rich
um and that has
you know it has its own kind of it has a
certain co it has a it has a negative
connotation
um but actually wealth building can be
um
it can be really powerful um it's
freedom building wealth building freedom
building
yeah
so it's
it's one of those things that it's
there's not enough nuance to the
conversation around these things and
it's hard to kind of have the
conversation around these things um
again going back to this anti-work thing
um one of the rules in the forum is you
just cannot talk about ceos
because um
more so from this kind of original core
group of people um again because it's
rooted in um marxism and anarchism there
is this fundamental belief that any ceo
is still
profiting off the labor
of the workers and so therefore it's
just not possible for them you know
there's no such thing as
yeah and there's no such thing as
benevolent capitalism um
which is i can i totally see where that
view comes from um
and you know what
what we're talking about in that respect
is on
such a massive level
but when we're talking about kind of you
know
ceos of tiny companies or ceos of
companies have won um building wealth
and redistributing it
that's you know it's possible it's
something that i kind of i even think
about just from my own just like in my
own little world is
um
so
if when i work with other creatives when
i collaborate on projects
increasingly i'm trying to do so on a
profit-sharing basis rather than paying
another if i'm working with another
freelancer increasingly i try to avoid
just paying them a flat fee and just
share the profit
because that to me sounds seems fairer
um and wouldn't it be great if that
worked on on a macro level
um
i doubt that me doing that is going to
is going to influence that but at least
in my own little orbit that's something
that
that's my little action
so
this is just a really long-winded way of
saying that um
when
there is a big element to all of the
productivity discussion which centers
around wealth and and money
and not enough of that is talked about
and it's a really important conversation
to have and a really big part of it
because to a large extent
the more
resources you have and the um
the wealthier you are the more
productive you can be um because just
for simple reasons of you can either
outsource stuff or you're not worrying
about that financial burden um one of
your earlier questions when you're
asking me you know kind of like how to
how do you
you know about being more creative
um
something that i think there is a direct
correlation between is
when my finances are in a good place
i feel i i can i get more done i can i
feel more creative i feel more
productive because i'm not i don't have
that there's no worry at the back of my
head of like oh my god how am i you know
i need to come up with an idea so that i
can um pay my bills um you know you that
heat gets taken off
um
so
anyway that's a
very potted kind of um
take on it but i do think there's a
really big chunk of this productivity
conversation that
directly relates to money
i agree i think that
the how would you say
negative
view of wealth acquisition isn't really
helping anybody um what the
beyond burger work crowd want to do is
they want people to be able to live the
sort of life that they want uh
unencumbered from uh the
vicissitudes of doing work but they
don't realize that you can actually
achieve that through work and
there will inevitably be a little bit of
um
resentment towards the people that do
you know if you're able to find your
freedom number by going freelance or by
working within a company and doing
whatever investing smartly uh that's the
same outcome you've managed to get the
same outcome but anyway uh people need
to go and subscribe to your sub stack
your newsletter's dope i really like it
it's at the intersection of all of the
things that bounce around inside of my
head to do with modern productivity and
stuff like that where should people go
they want to sign up to that or check
out the other things that you do
um so
my sub stack is at um it's such a long
i've got such a long name because i have
a long long my name is long but it's
anna
cojorado.substance.com but the best
place people can find me is
on twitter it's at anacod and um
everything basically is linked from
there so but there is no other anacorado
in the world so if you google me you
find all my stuff nice thanks anna
thanks very much this has been great
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace